when we met
i was younger
than a young thing can be
you were wet
you were hungry
you still needed me
you said i could fly
and i flew
i remember before
[Music]
you taught me to see not to see but to
really look deeper like
[Music]
and from your first word
mama
you shaped the boy i'd become
but the boy disappeared
lost to the years
and the man you became is a beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sick as i see what i've done
if i could just tell you
more that deserve those three little
words i can't find
there is no
other one you are my
mother my son
[Music]
[Music]
just a little bit
more than most do
you get on my nerves and i'm sure that i
get on your shirley we both do aren't we
supposed to
say what we're feeling instead i'm
concealing my heart and just offering
guile
and when you smile it's my reflection
[Music]
mixed with everything i fear
all of my flaws look what i've caused to
appear
why can't i say what you most need to
hear
don't leave me stuck in the dark
deer
oh
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
more than deserve those three little
words i can't find
there is no
other one you are my mother my son
you are mine
if i could just tell you that
you